ah pacific do we ready okay welcome
everybody we're playing yeah I guess
welcome to our recording sessions this
is what we do this is what we do here
okay on the youtubes gonna pick what we
want to play so what Pastor Bob that's
the bomb I don't know I thought these
are all I can yes so I like color crazed
I voted for color crazed Montag you guys
are picking [ __ ] I don't know oh we just
saw the bomb tagged we're idiots just
pick everything I got a lot of Christ oh
that was it we pick everything Oh we'll
play it like everyone that we picked oh
jeez
all right in the or murder passive all
right the player before it explodes so
this is the bomb
oh no we're closing this one is counting
on you you have to scare the initial
people around you
Oh what what what gotcha
oh no maybe since oh god oh my god oh my
god ridiculous game ever a hell yeah
you're stupid the big horse disappearing
Oh God
jeez dad okay you happy moving don't
forget the coffee oh [ __ ] the red things
kill you number one yeah we've got a
game that wages rec said I've won two
rounds Bob we have 50 left
let's calm down a little bit as we're
tired want to suck I'm calling it right
now
go away pink paste you guys at the end
repainted over everything you were doing
oh that's videos when I get stuck I
don't fully understand this one you
press X and you get bigger yeah you need
to be inflated and then you bounce
people around oh good oh no god oh no oh
man I went something visit god this is
insanity
Oh Bob tag again awesome I was so good
this is my animation of a shot be the
winner
no no get away from wait oh god no no no
wait it's like it'll it'll pass it with
man I'm I am I am the best at this
literally Oh like my bones have boobs
did you notice that my bones have you
telling them oh what your hat you know
ah right
Oh shite my baby
Oh didn't even matter gases mom's place
oh god dammit
yeah that you must have the most weren't
you everyone you ever had at the end was
it no well I had the most of it okay
what you doing [ __ ] you wait Oh get it
boy come here skeleton no I'm scary oh
wait what
Oh goddamn hat wait are you dead yeah
I'm dead
oh you killed me right away my default
why did that happen was you to win
oh god this be this so these are [ __ ]
hard
Lisa Oh whoop-whoop
how am I supposed to outrun each other
we're all the same speed you're just
gonna not die ah shite ha ha ha what is
this world all living before I so close
to you when the end was I never does
done finish what no no no go home we
just get away free guys for me get away
from me the hell this is good see I told
you wait is wrecking yeah no no no not
me this is my mode this is where I no no
no no no yes well I'm going to the trash
and now I'm gonna do it no oh damn it
Oh [ __ ] oh is that your question that's
my first win yeah the yeah first win 17
rounds and played on again toxic this
one sucks how do you blow oh gods
[ __ ] [ __ ] you have to tap X well I've
already been tapping apps how do it
sugar the blow you have to run into them
and you all bounce around like crazy did
that
I don't know he takes him I think the
game just picked someone on the server
to make everyone hate like with a fiery
walk away you Pig [ __ ] [ __ ] you um
you know it'd go away that's no no wait
alone on the bottom no one actually did
anything we need the bank right I
appreciated that I wasn't gonna say a
word
give me that hat [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] wait the best brown
hair now everywhere what the [ __ ] how do
I hang up how are we supposed to get the
[ __ ] up there oh no my head I'm Pierre
on you why did it not belong I didn't I
didn't ever touch the head ever that was
it
wait destroying us I don't like this
this guy like he made the server there
for like something something is weird
about that actress true shack true let's
be cool oh hey hi is a bad thing yeah
yes it is that is rude it's tough I
don't like this one yeah I don't really
get how do you win it this way I don't
think maybe you want to attack from the
top or something
whoa whoa God to be from the top god
damn you you're not gonna drop is very
bad I still don't know you guys you two
kill each other and I'll be right here
hop it what do I get big and I throw
myself I got y'all
how are you talking to Phil no I hate
feeling I don't know how you pop it I
don't know what happens I just try to
avoid the edges Oh
yes this is funny point miracle that
none of us none of us have any anywhere
near that number yes like we still have
like half the game to go oh oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh no oh no oh no God Almighty
oh wait I'm gonna win oh my god I'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] wait where'd you go
you [ __ ] [ __ ] no oh I don't know
oh just nothing black no I scared and
then you scared me and killed me somehow
even though I scared first I was beneath
you I was still a bro beneath you there
okay you're my [ __ ] speedrun no [ __ ]
here we go what oh come on I'd have been
serious [ __ ] lag god damn it okay
that's the wrong way Jack that's not the
way does yours guys keep saying poor
connection at the top no no it's
probably cuz what Ron Isley says poor
connection that's why we're training oh
no don't you even take this away from me
die look sick yet poisoning guys oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] mark know what everybody
there no one ever touched me they're
just this is screw aid screw oh no
Hannah love his gloominess come here no
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I like it back her
up the pet pet oh my god all the way
down dad no I just bend at the wrong
spot this hole
come on come on I had it for so long yes
uh it was cuz I made it all the way up
into the corner I hate this game yeah my
name is Terra I like twice our score
game is just the worst oh I was going
low Oh God Oh God Jackie unbelievable
[ __ ] gobbler ordered me you're just like
dude ah I don't care I'm still gonna get
salty at you
yeah what's fizzle floor they disappear
don't ya oh yeah oh oh can we have to
blow back power now no no no your logo
yeah oh god I hate it all Oh God keep
running oh I was still alive
you forgot to run yeah [ __ ] I was in I
was in the moving around when I died oh
okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no damn it oh gosh yeah I
press the button oh no Bob Wayne you got
rank no I I was on that top right corner
and then I just dropped out and murky oh
I thought you were anal is that still a
thing
merked commerce jerked Merc I'm blaming
lag on everything wait what's the game
with the ball oh come on please
no come here you [ __ ]
damn it you stay with you to stay with
me no no boobs I'm just cutting for
second place at this point because waves
run away with first so the real combat
officers go tear lately I've been
standing still hat come here I want you
oh [ __ ]
go ahead oh my oh [ __ ] it's just gonna
have a big hat [ __ ] is Oh
goodness GOP's titties oh no no oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no my hat no like way needs
any more points I did it Bob you were
catching up
no shut up I have but I'm not catching
up Oh deserve that you deserve that see
Jack and not fun is it mark my weight
has the advantage cuz he God waited like
pudding Vantage yeah I'm over here lives
me it's like it doesn't show up the
right time I was clear I was in the
valley where I was I was in the clear oh
my god
I was so fun how to blow back yeah I
don't know what to do you just have to
jump into people it's not that
calculated once you're puffing and you
jump in someone oh god I move honey
Hooper Manning Oh what I don't
understand what the [ __ ] happened
you're killing we died I guess oh good
okay get away from me
I hate you guys ah [ __ ] oh god those are
floor anymore oh god oh god oh god
I was still I was still I not shut up
you selling me when you jump too much
you weren't living enough I was moving
yeah but you're jumping too much moving
eerily gosh oh my god that's not the
right place of the [ __ ] here you [ __ ]
douche bag
oh god no oh I don't understand this
level oh god damn it's so hard to get up
there
yeah gee how about far you smell photo
photo damn oh I think what I didn't have
in the first half of the match just to
show the sport
this shows the bars [ __ ] not [ __ ] on my
screen touch the goddamn block
[ __ ] you wait fire jack
get him jack oh bloody I am so much Oh
God
ahahaha it is nice Cooper did uh what do
you want you're all terrible at this but
he still got five points did I yeah yeah
okay oh well I scared you good well now
I'm dead oh damn it whoa are you were
right next to me what here Jack to
undress away from me I don't believe you
that's ball fan Tigers a 93.48 percent
chance of something - oh my groin into
people oh no no oh my god damn it ah
what the [ __ ] I don't pop no yeah Jack
are you inflating yourself cuz you have
to inflate yeah we're all inflating
ourselves it just doesn't pop yeah I
don't know there's like no timing to the
back it's just random
oh you don't [ __ ] Bob hey Jack how's
it going hi oh wait is this what so
problem is so much oh my oh come on I
don't like how many more rounds we have
to play this crap game how many more
rounds can I just not have the bun
Oh God I want something yeah career is
awesome we could all go to the bar and
drink some bleach that'd be cool right
you know maybe show some shards of glass
in our eyes that be fun too
you know I just love hanging out with
you guys love you too buddy
hope you all die god damn it oh my god
I'm winning
oh no I say look back I thought it was
gonna end it was like I said I will blow
away dick
gah [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't I can't
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] hands in the [ __ ]
head oh yeah yeah wait no
Oh blast my [ __ ] like my chair Bruno
said to me you were nowhere near me no
chill thanks in my chair oh god my
garbage cans now fallen over oh my god
alright here we go
hang on yeah alright I was kicked by
hosts they probably I was like why was I
kicked by the host what [ __ ] I don't
know
I didn't hey oh yeah wasting roll it up
moving oh man
this is the last round anyway what I
said so it's a good came back to get
second place yeah share it break you it
broke I fell backwards I tried to fix it
and then the other leg broke and I
knocked over my there's garbage
everywhere
instead of a [ __ ] yes sticks well Wade
had a hundred and twenty eight point oh
that's not the last round they're
supposed to forty five rounds I don't
know why there's more no there you ever
played with four people before are you
guys that's why I'm gonna clean up my
garbage let's go no bigs attack never
just gone right